the world could be a pretty confusing
place these days there's so many virtue
signaling bonkers campaigns embarked
upon by the world brigade difficult to
know whether they're real or someone
who's having a laugh at our expense so i
decided to put it all to the test i sent
my two intrepid reporters josh and
archie to that hotbed of global
intellectualism oxford university to
test one of the biggest brains in the
country can tell the difference this is
woke
[Music]
jonah is here to play a game that we
like to revert it was uh
local jokes very very simple bunch of
headlines
yeah headlines some of our joke
headlines if you think it's a joke
headline what word do you say joke it's
a work headline you're going to go with
he's on fire welcome to oxford everybody
so the first one is walk or joke no no
it's one or the other yeah yeah
i'm putting language back here okay
let's start
three two one nope
you're no longer saying boys and girls
in recorded park greetings in order to
promote gender inclusion woke joke
i'm gonna say
clapping band at oxford university to
stop people being triggered not sure if
it's of people being triggered but i
think that is woke it was woke you think
i think i think it happened no no is it
woke or is it joke joke that's a joke i
remember this woke woke very good no no
sorry very good yes yes very good is it
woke or joke google launched his
inclusive language function to cut down
on politically incorrect words
woke
woke i think i saw that joke joke
incorrect woke guys do you want to play
woke or joke we can bring the game to
you and you win prizes big prizes huge
prizes
crazy prizes university of chester puts
trigger warning on harry potter hunger
games and northern lights
that's a joke joke
awake
it's woke ladies and gentlemen potato
head to lose mr title and gender neutral
rebrand welcome joke i think i've heard
that one jake break woke
gavin's pub under fire for renaming
ploughman's lunch to plant persons jokes
woke
so you're saying that happened that
happened yeah that did happen yay you're
saying yeah the fact it changed the fact
that you got it right um i got it right
the midwives told to say chest feeding
oh whoa what hang on i've got a finish
right have you ever watched mastermind
i've started so i finished midwives told
to stay chest feeding instead of
breastfeeding to be more trans-inclusive
joke that's woke okay we're joined by
louis now one of oxford university's
finest what do you study louis geography
you studied geography so not one of
oxford university's finest but anyway
louie's here i studied geography yeah
quite how kfc could be renamed to
kentucky fried cluckin as it moves away
from selling poultry joke correct joke
mcdonald's urged to ban happy meals
after pressure from mental health
campaigners
joke
uh joke uh that i'm afraid
what are you sure
no that's a joke you should start with
your first answer okay schools replace
detention with guided meditation
i think that sounds like a really good
idea so i'm hoping that one's woke it's
a joke it's obviously a joke california
prison to rebrand inmates as residents
to avoid defense
jokes
smoke no that's a joke i'm really sorry
woke
uh no opinion no opinion murdered your
mother would you call them a resume
yes yeah okay cool are you happy hi
casey i'm great how are you i'm great
good thank you you don't have to bend
down i do always get us both i mean he's
really very tall and you're really very
small yorkshire school makes the lord's
prayer gender neutral dropping our
father for our person
work woke no that's a joke unfortunately
linguistic dollars call for french
language to become gender-neutral
no that's a joke that's a joke
and they will do for what the time
children's charity calls for winnie the
pooh name change
joke doesn't seem sure i'm not sure it
is i'm afraid of joke well done hospital
trust to stop giving terminal diagnoses
instead we'll use terms sub optimal
outlook five seconds are you sure a
hundred percent are you sure
yes really giving you last chance change
your mind now joke uh
choke
woke
uh that i'm afraid is a joke school
calls for kids to be given emotional
absence to process deaths in popular
children's tv shows woke
really yes you want time off because
peppa pig died yes adam you sound like a
very proper oxford man adam i tried to
be bloody hell yeah engineering we've
just said engineering no one asked
engineering john's college
when people come to your party you go
hello who are you you go adam edmund tom
and jerry to be given trigger warning
against animal harm joke yeah there's a
giant jew well done uk university claims
future female monarchs should not be
called queen to avoid offending drag
artists joke
or joke joke that's a joke
joke you literally had to think about
that welcome to 2022 campuses so there
you have it turns out the people at
oxford university can't tell the
difference between real headlines or
ones we made up that was woke or joke
[Music]